around launches ballistic missiles at
Iraqi bases with US soldiers President
Trump makes a statement and the media
lose their ever loving minds I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
until my listeners secure their internet
join them and express it VPN comm /
Manuel with all of the craziness going
on in the world ranging from the
situation with Iran to impeachment you
may have noticed that prices of gold
have been spiking now might be a good
time to diversify your assets at least a
little bit and you know who I trust when
it comes to diversification of assets of
course I'm talking about my friends over
at Birch gold if you haven't yet taken
the first step of requesting a free
information kit on gold go ahead and do
it if you haven't converted a portion of
your eligible IRA or 401k to an IRA and
precious metals ask all your questions
to my friends over at Birch gold bird
school we'll go to work and make things
super simple for you no obligation you
have nothing to lose to take that first
step again when there is a lot of chaos
in the world people tend to rush to
precious metals because they've never
been worth zero and they are a good
hedge against inflation and uncertainty
in the market text Ben - 47 47 47 during
the month of January when you open an
IRA and precious metals you'll get a
signed copy of my book the right side of
history for free
again you have to text Ben - 47 47 47 to
get a signed copy of my book the right
side of history along with all those
other conditions sex Ben - 47 47 47
again this would be a good time to think
about diversifying because the world is
growing chaotic Birch gold can help you
make sense of it text Ben - 47 47 47
well the President of the United States
just exited the stage after making a
statement over the situation in Iraq and
Iran I'm gonna give you back run and
then we will inform you as to what
President Trump just had to say and what
it actually meant his speech was
actually quite good
the president's speech was given from a
teleprompter he did not take any
questions it lasted about 10 minutes and
he said everything that needed to be
said will go through his actual
statement in a second first the events
of last night which threw everybody into
a panic at least momentarily so after
the killing of kissimmee soleimani which
followed hard on the attempt to burn
down the United States Embassy in
Baghdad an act that was coordinated and
ordered by Soleimani and so Emani had
then come to Iraq to coordinate further
attacks the fact that the the fact that
the Iranians were going to respond after
soleimani was killed that was inevitable
we all knew it
Iran was
to do it everybody knew this was coming
and so the President of the United
States orders Soleimani taken out he has
taken out so as the head of the popular
local militia front which was
responsible for the Baghdad embassy
attack Trump orders the death of
Soleimani and we get these theatrics
these hysterics from the Iranian
government's the Ayatollah Khomeini
standing in front of the box containing
the remains of soleimani and weeping
they get hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people in the streets in
Tehran and we get the media losing their
minds over all of this obviously this is
going to be prelude for war and all of
the last 48 hours has been the media
basically suggesting that World War 3
was imminent well last night the
missiles started flying in the media
declared in the moment that World War
three was upon us that World War three
was upon us so what exactly happened
according to the UK Daily Mail Iran's
quote-unquote crushing revenge strike
against the u.s. largely failed to
materialize Wednesday as the country
launched 22 missiles against two
American air bases in Iraq but failed to
kill a single soldier while it appears
some missiles failed to explode on
impact from missed their targets
altogether US and European intelligence
sources said the regime deliberately
pulled its punches for fear of provoking
a disproportionate response threatened
by President Trump in other words these
missiles were flying in the immediate
response of the media where while here
it comes now the Iranians are mad now
the Iranians are gonna go full-out
and while the Iranians have been
engaging in low-level rocket attacks for
a very long time they've been doing it
for literally a year and they've been
engaging in attacks on American soldiers
going back decades but this was
something that was at least a little bit
new it was a ballistic missile attack
from Iranian soil into Iraq proper now
that is an act of war on rock I mean the
Iranians going into Iraq without
permission and attacking Iraqi bases
remember these are not US bases these
are our rocky bases where there are
coalition soldiers that is a distinction
that makes a difference if this was Iran
attacking Iraq that was an act of war
against Iraq and against US soldiers so
in that sense this was an escalation but
the fact that nobody was killed that
nobody was harmed that no casualties
happened that basically this appeared to
be Iran signaling to its people that it
was willing to respond but not willing
to go particularly far in order to do so
that basically Iran had been convinced
by Trump killing soleimani that if they
went hard back at Trump that Trump would
do something really escalatory that if
they had hit a US air base without any
sort of warning for exam
and they'd killed some American soldiers
the likelihood that Trump would have
then sunk their Navy was incredibly high
so if you look at Iran's strategic
vulnerability in the region their
ballistic missiles are not supremely
vulnerable because a lot of them are on
mobile launchers and they have lots and
lots of ballistic missiles that have
been developed over the years and also
with the help of Obama era cash because
remember the Obama administration
shipped 1.8 billion dollars in cash to
the Iranians allowed their their 150
billion dollars of withheld assets to
flow back into Iran tried to open the
world economy to Iran and Ron was
promptly using all of that money in
order to build up its conventional
assets it's it's military its terrorist
groups all around the Middle East
stationed around the Middle East they're
building up their ballistic missiles so
Iran really has sort of three assets
that were at its disposal one is its
ballistic well for their ballistic
missile system their ballistic missile
system they are not supremely
sophisticated ballistic missiles but
they are ballistic missiles and they are
widespread and they're on mobile the
launchers many of them those would be a
little bit hard to take out the second
asset is the enormous Iranian
Revolutionary Guard which is a very very
large standing army but as a
conventional army and would have to
cross over conventional borders which
would precipitate actual international
action against against Iran then there
was the Iranian Navy which is the weak
spot for Iran because their Navy is
pretty rinky-dink they have a few
submarines that might be somewhat hard
to locate but their surface ships are
really not a tremendous threat
especially if they don't get to take the
first punch and then they have their
terrorist groups around the region all
of whom are not really prepared for war
last night Iran threatened that if there
was some sort of retaliation from the
United States that they would activate
their terrorist groups like Hezbollah
against Israel husband Otto's not want
to go to war with Israel right now
because Israelis Israel's military has
been prepping for this for years really
since the 2007 southern Lebanon war and
so Israel would go in and wipe them off
the map pretty quickly so Iran is in a
strategically vulnerable position their
economy is incredibly weak and so they
did sort of the minimum of what they had
to do to signal to their people that
they're mad but let's put it this way
soli money was a top leader in Iran he
was also a their terror leader he was
the number two he was widely perceived
to be possibly the successor to the
number one I tell her how many Hey so
Amman he gets taken out imagine in the
United States the equivalent let's
imagine that a foreign actor takes out
the vice president of the United States
the Secretary of Defense the head of the
CIA and the head of the FBI all in one
because
is basically what so many money was and
imagine that then there are pictures on
television of millions of American
mourners in the streets and imagine
there are pictures of the presidents of
the United States openly weeping over
the corpse of this person or these
people and then imagine that the
response was we fired 22 ballistic
missiles all of which failed to kill
anybody who had actually ordered the
attack or any of the soldiers on the
other side the American people would
rightly consider that to be an act of
weakness
well what happened last night was an
active weakness and it is now apparent
it's becoming more and more apparent
that it was a deliberate act of weakness
because the Iranian government did not
want to provoke a serious response from
the United States as the Daily Mail is
reporting Iraqi Prime Minister Adil
Abdul Mahdi said that Iran warned him
about the attack on the Anil Assad and
Erbil air bases an hour before they took
place and then Abdullah Mahdi turned
around and he warned Iraqi and US troops
to take shelter Finland in Lithuania
said they were also informed to get
their soldiers to safety in other words
this was staged okay this is what it
sounds like it sounds like this was
staged it sounds like the Iranian
government basically signaled to the
Iraqis listen we got to do something
because otherwise it looks like our
regime is so weak that we can't even
retaliate in response to the debt they
the killing of one of our leaders and so
here's what we gonna do we're gonna fire
some ballistic missiles it'll be a lot
of sound and fury signifying nothing
because we're warning you beforehand to
get your people out so you get your
people out and nobody gets killed we get
to claim that we took a crushing
response to all of this and then you get
to basically claim that we didn't do any
damage and everybody goes home happy and
that is effectively what happened last
night
now the the Iranian government played it
up to the hilt and one Iranian official
that the Iranians really did play this
up the Iranian state TV was reporting
that Ayatollah Khomeini was coordinating
the attacks himself which was supposed
to be an an indicator of the seriousness
of the Iranian respond to his MSNBC
reporting on that last night we have
reports as well from the IRGC that
Ayatollah Khamenei the supreme leader of
this country was in the control room
coordinating all of these attacks
they're also reporting that Iran Iran's
air force has been deployed
and they are ready to intercept any
attacks from the United States Ayatollah
Ali Khamenei then's described the
attacks as a quote slap in the face of
America but he admitted they were not
enough to avenge Soleimani he did a
televised address where he promised
Iranians the true revenge would be
kicking US forces out of the Middle East
altogether the problem is that the
strategy he just pursued after me that
more difficult so the media were
claiming yesterday and basically since
soleimani is killing that killing
soleimani was going to prompt a rock to
throw the u.s. out of iraq that is just
sheer nonsense they were they were
proclaiming that the Parliament had
voted that the United States should
leave there's only one problem only the
cabinet can ask the United States to
leave there is no cabinet in Iraq
because the acting Prime Minister has
been under significant pressure to step
down specifically because Iran was
dominating his foreign policy they in
fact the vote that was taken in the
Iraqi parliament was taken with barely a
quorum available every Sunni legislature
every Kurdish legislator boycotted the
vote and the vote was non-binding so
none of that made any sense and then
Iran actually made its case worse
yesterday because Iran is claiming that
the United States should pull out of
Iraq and then saying that the Iraqi
people want the United States out of
Iraq there's only one problem with that
everybody in Iraq who is not Shia knows
that the minute the United States is out
Iran rushes in and takes over every bit
of the government they understand that
so and having Iranian missiles flying
into a rocky territory trying to kill
Iraqi citizens is not a very good way of
showing that you don't have territorial
aspirations to take over Iraq so
actually this is pretty
counterproductive for the ayatollahs
they're put between a rock and a hard
place they're sort of boxed in here and
so they lashed out in the most
minimalist way they could deliberately
apparently avoiding casualties so that
they couldn't give Trump an excuse to go
after their Navy or go after any of
their important military sites now the
media last night played this is an act
of sheer panic World War three is upon
us it's a massive war I've been saying
for weeks when no one wants to go to war
nobody's going to war the Iranians don't
want war because if there's a war
Ayatollah Khomeini that dude is dead
okay if there's a war the Iranian Navy
is gone if there is a war the United
States military is the best war making
force in the history of the world the
United States doesn't want war because
we don't want to occupy anybody because
we are not interested in a protracted
conflict no one no one from Tucker
Carlson to Donald Trump to me nobody
wants war with Iran no one is interested
in a full-scale military conflict with
Iran but that means there's no
going to be a full-scale military
conflict with Iran and this entire
situation does give the UI to the notion
pushed by the media and pushed by the
Obama administration that the only two
alternatives were appeasing the Iranians
or going to full-scale war with them
that was alive from the outset it is
alive today the two choices were not
signing giant checks to a terrorist
entity or going to complete war with the
terrorist density one of the
possibilities is deterrence and that's
what Trump was reestablishing here and
successfully re-established here Iranian
television tried to claim that 80
American tourists were killed but that
figure was quickly rubbished by Iraqi
and US officials according to the Daily
Mail Iranian president Hassan rouhani
said they show what we didn't retreat in
the face of America this was an attempt
to save face
he says if America has committed a crime
it should know that it will receive a
decisive at response if they are wise
they won't take any other action at this
juncture so basically they're trying to
claim now that they have somehow that
they are the barking dog and they have
scared away the united states absolute
sheer nonsense that they understood that
if they killed an American Trump was
going to unleash the beast and so they
called in advance the Iraqi government
and warned them what was coming hey by
the way this was there a bunch of weird
incidents incidents that happened last
night there were a couple of earthquakes
in your anaronnie and nuclear facility
don't know what that means we also don't
know what it means that the Ukrainian
Airlines Boeing 737 caught fire and
crashed near Tehran killing all 177
passengers and crew including 63
Canadians and three Britons it is
unclear whether in fact that plane was
shot down and the black box is not being
is not being released at this point
President Trump for his part credits the
early warning system that had been
established for preventing casualties
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you need to protect yourself online so
right now we are seeing widespread spate
like a huge spate of attacks globally by
the Iranian government against
particular websites and they share
they've hacked like actual private
people before they hacked Sheldon
Adelson a few years back you see hackers
all the time looking for information and
it's not just governments sometimes big
tech just monitoring you or it's the
government checking in to you and
sometimes it's hackers you just want
your credit card information you ought
to be protecting yourself online you
must protect yourself no matter whether
you're famous or whether or not whether
you're a target of a foreign country or
whether you're not expressvpn is the
best way to do this expressvpn does not
log at your data there are lots of
really cheap or free VP
actually make money by selling the data
they say they are protecting to ad
companies expressvpn has developed a
technology called trusted server that
makes it impossible for their servers to
log any of your information they are
fast it's easy you install it on your
computer with one click it is now
running in the background of your
computer there's a reason the TechRadar
the verge CNET and many other tech
experts rate expressvpn the number one
VPN in the world
I love expressvpn I've been using it for
years I want to protect myself you
should protect yourself as well use my
link expressvpn comm slash pen today get
an extra three months for free on a
one-year package that is expressive VPN
comm slash pen again visit expressvpn
comm slash Ben to learn more that's
expressvpn comm slash Ben so according
to a US official telling USA Today US
officials did have advance warning of
Iran's missile assault the damage to to
Iraqi bases housing US and coalition
forces a hangar at al-assad a sprawling
complex at 100 miles west of Baghdad
that houses about 1500 coalition forces
was severely damaged according to a US
official speaking to USA Today on the
condition of anonymity the official
added the early warning systems gave US
forces advanced knowledge that the
missiles had been launched it's also
possible by the way that we're hearing
about the early warning system to cover
up for the fact that Iran actually
created a back channel to the Iraqi
government saying that they were not
going to kill Americans
so get your guys out right now because
the last thing we want is a full-scale
war with you guys we've now saved face
you get to claim that we were a failure
we all go home happy and then maybe we
work toward negotiating a new agreement
the fact is that what Iran just did
forces the Europeans into a bad
situation the Europeans would love
nothing better than to go back to the
failed jcpoa the Iran nuclear deal
negotiated by the Obama administration
that was basically an act of appeasement
by the way that sucker was 10 years long
that was set to expire like very very
soon it was signed in 2013 so it's been
a while and that thing was was already
going to be defunct and Iran was gonna
start its nuclear testing its nuclear
missiles program its nuclear weapons
program right back up in the next couple
of years
no matter what so Trump saying that we
need to cut a new deal with Iran and
that that has to be done on the basis of
no more terrorism no more ballistic
missile testing no more nuclear
technology that is exactly right one of
the things you keep hearing from the
media is that the Iran nuclear deal is
keeping Iran and check well only with
regards to their nuclear program at best
at best in reality what it was doing is
bribing them but the possibility of
greater reach
power and economic strength so that one
day they could move forward with an
actual nuclear weapons program that is
why the Democratic takes on all of this
are so silly so in the in the middle of
all of this the the Iranians have
basically back down
Iran issued all of these sort of empty
warnings one of the iranian leaders
tweeted a picture of the Iranian flag
supposedly sort of the response to Trump
tweeting a picture of the American flag
as he treated the Iranian flag because
wow look at us were just like the United
States yeah except for the fact that you
shot a bunch of missiles and didn't even
hit a camel in the ass so there's that
and then around and should further
warning saying they're going to attack
Dubai that they were going to attack
Haifa in Israel which of Tel Aviv which
of course is just silly talk and then
javad zarif basically the foreign
minister who is talking tough just a few
moments ago hey all of a sudden he is
backing down on Twitter he said Iran
took and concluded proportionate
measures in self-defense under article
51 of the UN Charter targeting base from
which cowardly armed attack against our
citizens and senior officials were
launched it wasn't against your citizens
you literally had terrorists in the
country of Iraq a foreign country where
you were facilitating terror terror
attacks we do not seek escalation or war
but will defend ourselves against any
aggression that was Arif basically
saying we're done now we're done we're
not we're finished at this point and
Trump then tweeted out okay fine you
want to be done I guess we're done he
treated out last night all as well
missiles launched from Iran at two
military bases located in Iraq
assessment of casualties and damages
taking place now so far so good
if the most powerful and well-equipped
military anywhere in the world by far I
will be making a statement tomorrow
morning play then this morning President
Trump actually made his statement that's
why we delayed the onset of the show
this morning he opened by walking out
flanked by his national security team
the Joint Chiefs of Staff as well his
Secretary of Defense and vice president
and he said right off the bat Iran will
never have a nuclear weapon like this
was his first statement he the only
difference between Trump and Obama is
that Trump actually means it see the
thing is that if you say never what that
means is beyond your term Obama was fine
with Iran getting a nuclear weapon he
just wanted them to do it a few years
down the line when he thought he
couldn't be blamed for it and he sort of
wanted to appease them until that time
Trump actually means this thing and he
showed it by killing soleimani here is
President Trump this morning
as long as I'm president of the United
States Iran will never be allowed to
have a nuclear weapon good morning I'm
pleased to inform you the American
people should be extremely grateful and
happy no Americans were harmed in last
night's attack by the Iranian regime we
suffered no casualties all of our
soldiers are safe and only minimal
damage was sustained at our military
bases our great American forces are
prepared for anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world that of course is exactly true the
fact that Iran backed off at the signal
again when no one wants World War 3
World War 3 ain't happened and also
worth noting I mean this is sort of a
didactic point but it's true if the
United States had actually gone into a
shooting North Run that's not World War
ok world war 3 actually would involve
coalitions of people siding against the
United States the Russians would not
have gotten involved the Chinese would
not have gotten involved it would have
been a regional war more like the Gulf
War the first Gulf War the technical war
Vietnam it would not have been World War
3 World War 3 actually requires there to
be serious risk of heavy American
casualties it requires there to be many
other countries involved it would have
been an actual war between Iran and the
United States that would have been proxy
wars between Hezbollah and Israel none
of that is happening ok I'm just making
the point that the the overblown talk by
the media even in the worst case
scenario was indeed overblown talk by
scenario but nobody even wanted the
regional war right nobody was for this
it was so funny watching people in the
media ranging from the sort of
isolationist right to the radical left
and the mainstream was suggesting that
there were people inside the
administration who are desperate for war
I saw people tweeting last night that
John Bolton wanted war not John Bolton
when he was the NSA once it's something
like this what he wanted was we kill off
your worst people and then you end up
cower in cowardly fashion you end up
sending us messages to get our people
out so that you don't kill our people
because you don't want us to break
right that's exactly what happened
President Trump says there will be
consequences for the actions of run last
night but they're gonna come in the
economic and diplomatic sphere which of
course is exactly the right move the
fact is now what are the Europeans gonna
do side with the Iranians and in fact
it's obvious that that's not what is
going to happen the fact is that the the
UK has already come out against Tehran
Boris Johnson saying the United States
has a right to defend its soldiers
saying that he is going to work with
President Trump you're going to see the
other Western countries come around on
this Boris Johnson said today that the
United States has the right to protect
its troops and khun's and told Iran to
de-escalate so this is moving in
president Trump's direction it turns out
that deterrence has always been and will
continue to be good policy president
Trump announced this morning that there
would in fact be new sanctions on Iran
and as you'll see he then urged the
Europeans to get on board as we continue
to evaluate options in response to
Iranian aggression the United States
will immediately impose additional
punishing economic sanctions on the
Iranian regime these powerful sanctions
will remain until Iran changes its
behavior okay and then president Rome
came out and he suggested that other
countries need to pull out of the failed
jcpoa the Iran nuclear deal and it's
time to actually negotiate a deal that
contains Iran in tatters Iran again the
biggest problem with the Iranian nuclear
deal was not with regard to the nuclear
program yes it was a problem that the
verification procedures which were
heavier than other verification
procedures still were not completely
bulletproof the bigger problem was that
it basically just said to Iran okay you
develop as much as you could possibly
want to develop your conventional
military your terrorists branches your
economy and then in 10 years you can
develop a nuke that was basically what
the jcpoa said and then you had the
Obama team declaring victory which again
is sort of like a person walks into the
doctor's office and says I have cancer
and also I have a cold and the doctor
says okay well here's what gonna do
here's some nyquil that should take care
of some of your cold symptoms won't cure
the cold but it'll take care of some of
your cold symptoms put them off for a
little bit and you're fine turns out
you're fine now and presently wait hold
on but I also have cancer and actually
it doesn't matter we're not going to
ignore the cancer can the fact is that
Iran's a terrorist threats on the world
stage and its growth as a regional
power are a significantly greater danger
than its mere nuclear program alone it's
when the nuclear program is attached to
a broader terror threat then it becomes
a real threat to the world the Obama
administration facilitated the terror
threat well quote-unquote delaying the
nuclear program for a certain preset
period of time President Trump says
listen this deal was bad it was always
bad in fact President Trump suggested in
this speech correctly that the ballistic
missiles that were fired at this Iraqi
air base could have been paid for by
Obama cash because again it was the
Obama administration's stated position
that the Iraq that the Iranians could
use money from the opened economy and
from the United States to build its
Terra capacity John Kerry's
openly admitted this in March 2016 he
said of course they're gonna use it for
terrorism sure they might use it for
ballistic missiles ok those ballistic
missiles were falling on Iraqi and
American troops last night or would have
been if the Iranians near pockys ahead
of time here's President Trump saying
other countries need to pull out of this
crap deal the time has come for the
United Kingdom Germany France Russia and
China to recognize this reality they
must now break away from the remnants of
the Iran deal or jcpoa and we must all
work together toward making a deal with
Iran that makes the world a safer and
more peaceful place ok that of course is
exactly true that is exactly true and in
a second we're gonna get to president
Trump's conclusion of the speech and
some of the other stuff that he said
during the speech which is pretty
important then we'll get to the media
response which again was wildly
overblown throughout this was just it
was plain bad media coverage it is
obvious that many in the media we're
rooting for Trump to be humiliated and
that's not just that's not really cuz
they love Iran as much as it is because
they love Obama and they've been trying
to justify Obama's garbage foreign
policy for a decade at this point we'll
get to more of that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that it
is the new year that means that you're
gonna be sending a lot of business mail
right you run a business or you or
you're at home and you're gonna be
sending birthday gifts Valentine's Day
is coming up right lots of times you're
gonna be sending mail do you really
wanna schlep all that stuff over the
post office post offices grape you want
to schlep all that stuff over to the
post office or do you want to do all
this stuff from the comfort and security
of your own home or your own business
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service directly
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps comm you get
five cents off every first-class stamp
and up to 40% off priority meals
actually cheaper than going to the post
office not to mention it's a fraction of
the cost of those expensive that postage
meters stamps comm it's a no-brainer
it saves you time it saves you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps common
value your time and value your money why
wouldn't you use stamps calm so head on
over to stamps calm no risk with my
promo code Shapiro you get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and the digital scale
no long term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that is stamps comm
promo code Shapiro stamps calm and never
go to the post office again now the way
that you know that this whole thing has
de-escalated is that the oil prices
actually dropped this morning they
spiked last night in the aftermath of
the attack but oil prices dropped by two
percent reversing that earlier spike
according to CNBC calm after Aaron's
rocket attack on American forces in Iraq
failed to destroy a major energy
infrastructure that could have disrupted
global crude supply more importantly it
was pretty obvious that this was not
going to escalate to a giant war now
does that mean that Iran isn't going to
continue acting out and of course
they're gonna continue acting out in
low-level terrorist ways they will plan
attacks in the West that they think
cannot be traced back to them this is
what they've done they have a longer
time horizon than any president every
president basically has a four year time
horizon Iran has a decade's long time
horizon so they can wait a couple of
years to quote-unquote retaliate and
then claim that the retaliation is in
response to Soleimani so this does not
end the Iranian threat by any stretch of
the imagination but we have certainly
deterred them from taking overt actions
like burning US embassies and trying to
kill American soldiers at least under
President Trump now President Trump at
the end of his speech this morning he
suggested listen now what we would like
to do is come back to the table and
renegotiate and improved jcpoa right
that includes ballistic missile testing
that includes a terror funding he said
listen this is very easy you want to
have a good future just stop being
terrorists here's President Trump
talking to the Iranian people directly
finally to the people
and leaders of Iran we want you to have
a future and a great future one that you
deserve one of prosperity at home and
harmony with the nations of the world
the United States is ready to embrace
peace with all who seek it I want to
thank you and God bless america thank
you very much thank you
so listen everybody wants to back off
right now the Iranians better back off
and this is what they know again the
greatest indicator that this deterrent
act worked is that the Iranians were
notifying the Iraqis that the missiles
were coming and that the United States
and the Iraqis were able to get out of
the way let Iran say faced the Iranians
again after all of that dog and pony
show after the entire millions in the
street outraged people beating at their
breasts gnashing wailing of teeth
sackcloth and ashes the Ayatollah is
standing over the coffin of Soleimani
and weeping his eyes out the Ayatollah
in the command center directing the
attacks it turns out that this is it if
this is it that's a huge win for Trump
huge win for Trump huge win for the
United States deterrence reestablished
at least at a very baseline level it
doesn't mean this is the end of the
battle it does mean that deterrence is a
thing again president Trump then re up
to the game right he gave Iran a
face-saving way out he baited in the
speech he did not he did not overstate
how ineffective the Iranian missile
attacks were he didn't try and shove the
Iranians face in it which would again
put the Iranians in the position of
having to try to do something else in
order to say faced with their own
population he did give them a way out by
citing the early warning system he said
Iran's us appear to be standing down
he also said people have been tolerating
at their behavior for decades those days
are now over obviously the killing of
Soleimani says that directly to the
Iranians Trump described soleimani in
full detail I mean this was one of his
better addresses it really was it was
short it was sweet yes it was on
teleprompter but teleprompter Trump can
be very good because when he reads the
teleprompter prompter properly that is
good now the media will be mocking his
pronunciation who cares none of that
matters Barack Obama's pronunciation was
impeccable especially when he said
things like Pakistan but it doesn't
matter the pronunciation doesn't matter
it's the message that matters Trump said
that the failure of the Obama deal was
resulted in additional Iranian
aggression and and around the Middle
East not just with
to the United States which of course is
true he called on other countries to
join the United States he said he would
ask NATO to become more involved in the
process which is perfectly appropriate
and he mentioned the fact that the
United States is in very strong position
to take really crucial sanctions against
the Iranian said listen we are energy
independent we do not need Iranian oil
we don't need Middle East oil period he
said I've been rebuilding the military
so don't this is Trump in a in a rather
subtle way actually saying just don't f
with us guys like don't don't try this
again just stop and now the media's
response to all this was just
unbelievable last night incredible last
night because the media that their
narrative here was not the deterrence
was being reestablish there are
narratives that a madman was leading us
to the brink of war with these pitiful
Iranians who had of course been
converted into the Swiss by the jcpoa
that the Iranian nuclear deal had
magically turned the ayatollah khomeini
into into a Western European leader
suddenly he was Emmanuel macron and
basically Soleimani was Justin Trudeau
just a little bit more angry with a
beard and and that was all because of
the jcpoa basically the Iran nuclear
deal had dfangs the amount of the
Iranians and this is why you got Ben
Rhodes who's the architect of the Iran
nuclear deal who lied openly to the
American people about the moderation
inherent in the Iranian government that
they were about to moderate if only we
sent them cash and last night he was
tweeting out things like this didn't
need to happen you're right it didn't
need to happen you could have stood up
to the Iranians the way Trump did but
instead you decided to pansy out which
is exactly what the Obama administration
did the media have an interest in
upholding that narrative that is the
common threads in the media coverage
sure the media narrative is that
everything was hunky-dory until Trump
pulled out of the Iran nuclear deal
at which point Iran randomly started
acting nasty again because they hate
Trump and if it weren't for that bad
orange man orange man bad bad orange man
then everything would've been hunky-dory
in the Middle East that ignores the
thousands of dead Americans due to
Iranian involvement in Iraq it ignores
the hundreds of thousands of dead
Muslims in Syria backed by solely
Monte's play in Syria it ignores the
build-up of Hezbollah's military force
in the wrecking of Lebanon which was an
Iranian development it ignores the fact
that Iraq has continued to be a roiling
sectarian hellhole because of the
Iranian involvement in Iraq it ignores
the attacks on Saudi oil facilities it
ignores the consistent monthly attacks
rocket attacks on America
basis it ignores the attacks on shipping
against non-american targets in the
Strait of Hormuz and the fact is that
the Iranians have been pursuing
terrorism for two literally decades that
escalated in the immediate aftermath of
the jcpoa right before Obama left office
the Iranians took a bunch of Americans
hostage right they took a bunch of
American military men hostage and then
Trump and then Obama had to basically
wheedle it out of them but they a
narrative again from the media side is
that this is all Trumpy and craziness so
the problem is this didn't result as
they wanted it's a result if the media
had its way we would be at war right now
if the media had its way Iran would have
retaliated much more harshly they would
have killed Americans so I'm not saying
the American media are rooting for the
death of American soldiers they are
rooting for an outcome bad for Trump's
that they can prop up their narrative
and if that out comment that is bad for
Trump involves more American assets
being put in danger they are happy you
could see the celebration in media last
night the the Finley veiled celebration
in media last night when Iran started
firing missiles when it turned out it
was a big nothing you can see the
disappointment this morning lawrence
O'Donnell is a perfect example of this
over at MSNBC lawrence O'Donnell
actually tweeted Trump wagged the dog
now the dog is wagging Trump it's
celebrating the idea that the Trump had
wagged the dog in order to avoid
impeachment coverage but now he had lost
control of the situation and the media
need this narrative because again the
narrative is that the Iranians were
perfectly reasonable that Obama had made
them perfectly reasonable and that Trump
just drove them mad because Trump is a
madman Jim Acosta over at CNN doing the
same routine Jim Acosta who doesn't know
his ass from his elbow suggesting last
night this is what the experts feel this
is exactly what the experts feared oh my
god Jim Acosta by the way ladies finding
you somebody who loves you like Jim
Acosta loves him some Jim Acosta the
president's attention has been gotten by
the Iranians no question about it and
getting back to what I was saying
earlier wolf this this is exactly what
many foreign policy and national
security analysts feared here in
Washington a lot of Democrats have been
talking about over the last 72 hours
that the president by by targeting
Soleimani has essentially set this chain
events a chain of events into motion and
the question is whether the president
will be able to get on top of it and
handle it
well you know the Jim
- looking real sad about that this is
what the experts feared it's what they
feared Chris Hayes over at MSNBC doing
the same thing it's strategically and
morally a disaster to go to war with
rock no one's going to war with mom but
you're gonna have to explain how to
moral disaster to kill the leading
terrorists in the Middle East
responsible for literally tens of
thousands of deaths most of the Muslim
before we go I just want to say this
very clearly that a war with Iran is
madness and it is strategically and
morally a disaster in the making and
don't believe anyone who tells the other
wise again they're setting up that false
narrative again and again that
deterrence is full-scale war and that
appeasement is the only solution because
that was the Obama solution was
impeachment get some more of the media
coverage which was egregious and which
of the media had the right would have
driven Iran to new rounds of actual
violence against Americans because the
Iranians are watching the media coverage
- they are yeah we'll get to more of
this in just one second but first if you
are not already subscriber you're really
missing out head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe for as little
as ten bucks a month you get our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library so
what the bonus content and our exclusive
daily water app which is a pretty great
feature if you haven't checked it out
yet if you choose the new All Access
plan you'll get all of that plus the
legendary leftist yours tumbler and our
brand-new asked me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our host writers special guests
on a weekly basis like tonight for
example we have a daily wire backstage
and then all of the hosts of daily we're
backstage will be joining you online to
ask your questions so stop depriving
yourself come join the fun we're the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so it's all about the narrative all
about the narrative and the narrative
absolutely collapsed in on the Democrats
last night when the Iranian response was
not only ineffectual
but apparently telegraphed to America
and her allies to avoid Iran having to
up the ante okay but if you listen to
the way Democrats have been talking
about all this again it is to preserve
the Obama era narrative defend the
precious precious defend the precious at
all cost Barack Obama is the precious
the Iran nuclear deal is the precious it
was garbage from day one anyone who
watched foreign policy knew that it was
garbage from day one this was Neville
Chamberlain desk appeasement of the
worst regime on planet Earth and the
fact is that the media are fully
invested in so are the Democrats in
defending that garbage strategy and the
only way to do that is by declaring that
Donald Trump is a madman in trying to
reestablish deterrence and that's why
you see Nancy Pelosi yesterday lamenting
needless American provocation she
tweeted yesterday closely monitoring the
situation following bombings targeting
US troops in Iraq by the way her close
monitoring involved her going to some
sort of fundraising events I believe
said we must ensure the safety of our
servicemembers including ending needless
provocations from the administration and
demanding that Iran cease its violence
America in the world cannot afford war
what would be those needless
provocations killing the world's leading
terrorists so Imani a man responsible
again for thousands and thousands and
thousands of dead Americans and Iraqis
and Syrians and Lebanese and Yemenis
that and Iranians by the way that would
those be the needless provocations then
there's John Kerry saying it's it it's a
tragedy that Donald Trump rushed a
confrontation if he had been me he just
would have signed to try and track to
the ayatollahs so they could have used
it to kill more people and then declared
that peace had been established here's
John Kerry who's beginning to resemble
more and more something from tails of
the crêpes here's the former Secretary
of State now we're seeing the
repercussions of going back to where we
were when we began the process of trying
to eliminate a nuclear weapon I think
it's a tragedy for the world that
instead of diplomacy this administration
has rushed to confrontation and if this
develops into a tit-for-tat
increased effort it will become a war
that is needless it didn't have to
and it will be a reckless war of choice
by the president United States is the
president of the United States
responsible for Iran being a terrorist
entity for the last 40 years also here
are my medals from Vietnam because I'm a
terrible person John Kerry that that man
was the 2004 Democratic nominee speaking
by the way of the 2004 Democratic
National Convention Michael Moore was
tweeting out this morning
pictures from soleimani funeral with the
tens of thousands of people on the
street saying is there any general in
America who would get this kind of
adoration that guy Michael Moore that
schmuck who is begging in in Farsi in
badly translated Farsi from google
translate the Iranians not to hit
America just yesterday that schmuck was
in a presidential box of Jimmy Carter at
the 2004 Democratic National Convention
talk about a party that's lost its way
by the way the idea that Donald Trump
rushed to confrontation for a year he
did basically nothing as a run up the
ante he did nothing when there was when
there was there were attacks in the in
the Straits of Hormuz he did nothing
when Saudi oil facilities were targeted
he did nothing when an American drone
was shot down seriously so this idea
that Trump is rushing to war is such
absolute absolute crap Joe Biden of
course defending the precious as well he
has to he was the vice president when
the garbage Iran nuclear deal went
forward he says we brought the world
together over Iran we did we brought it
together over brought the world together
over Iran if by that you mean this was
the Munich Agreement then sure sure I
don't think the secretary knows what
he's talking about there look what we
were able to do is bring together the
world to see to it that Iran they would
not be able to get a nuclear weapon
period and well I guess that was the
only the only issue on the table was
Iran getting a nuclear weapon the only
issue on the table because again the
Obama administration played doctor who
ignores the cancer but treats the cold
symptoms that that's exactly what they
did Joe Biden has been wrong on every
major foreign policy issue of his entire
career by the way speaking of Joe Biden
the man can't even keep Iran in Iraq
straight he gave a little speech
yesterday in which he was ripping on
Trump's Iranian foreign policy and then
he just mixed up Iran in Iraq because
the dude is barely functional at this
point the rant Parliament the rant
Parliament voted to eject all Americans
and coalition forces in the country here
on the Iraqi parliament there
countries you do not only that the Iraqi
parliament did not votes reject all
American forces from the country they
issued a non-binding resolution in which
literally half the Parliament abstained
and walked out because it turns out that
she Adama nated sections of Iraq are not
fond of the United States but the the
propaganda that is issue I mean I've
never whenever that when it comes to
issues in foreign policy the media just
become the DNC that's they merge and the
media which sometimes tries to hide it a
little bit it just ends immediately
anything Democrats do on foreign policy
is good anything Republicans do is bad
war in Iraq very very bad pursued by a
Republican pullout from Iraq
precipitously gliding leading to the
rise of Isis good war with regard to
Afghanistan very bad when a Republican
pursues it when pursued by Barack Obama
very good hitting Soleimani very bad
drone war for years by Barack Obama very
good war in Libya very very good because
pursued by Barack Obama killing of
Muammar Qaddafi very good burning of US
Embassy in Benghazi not that big a deal
burning of US Embassy in Baghdad very
big deal when when it's under Trump I
mean the media just become a mouthpiece
for whichever Democrats are in power
that's all that happens here yeah this
is a false narrative it is a giant gas
lighting effort that has been pursued
from the very beginning by the Obama
administration and now it is carried
forward a few years in the media are
just parroting this stuff as wrote
senator Tammy Duckworth of Wisconsin I
believe she came out and she says that
what's happening here is that Iran is
winning because Iraq is asking us to
leave again Iraq did not ask us to leave
the prime minister of Iraq did not ask
us to leave the Prime Minister of Rock
is powerless anyway right now he's the
acting Prime Minister because he's been
forced into a position of powerlessness
by his own population which feels that
he has been counting too much to Iran
here's Tammy Duckworth just saying
something that's absolutely untrue the
incompetence of this president as
commander in chief has actually achieved
the end goal that Iran wants in the
region you have to remember Rachel that
we actually since October have had
protests in Iraq against Iranian
influence by Iraqi people you know
within the space of just a couple of
days with this poor decision made by
this president we have now turned that
around so that now Iraq II the Iraqi
parliament has voted to kick us out of
their country and we have now turned a
sentiment into one that is much more Pro
Iranian in
Rocka and we're elsewhere in the Middle
East as well so it's always a myth you
think that Sunnis are desperately
mourning the loss of soleimani you think
Sunni Iraqis are desperately mourning
the loss of soleimani do you really
believe that the Kurds are desperately
mourning the loss of soleimani the Kurds
who are not exactly friends with the
Iranians like this whole thing is just
it's ridiculous and it's based on bad
information and the media understanding
that most people don't understand
anything like the complexities of Middle
Eastern politics Benjamin Haddad who is
a who is the director of the future
Europe initiative at the Atlantic
Council and no friend to President Obama
to President Trump he's tweeted out this
threat and this is exactly right at this
time of their presidencies Trump's two
predecessors had started wars in the
Middle East he has not the apocalyptic
commentary these last few days has
completely ignored from famous
reluctance to use force especially for
broad value-based objectives the
sulemani killing was about brutally but
punctually re-establishing escalation
dominance after Iran stepped up
nefarious activities drone destruction
strike on Saudi Arabia attack against US
embassy and broke an explicit red line
with the killing of an American citizen
the Iranian response and especially the
Zarif tweet seemed to show that Iran got
the message it had no choice but to
respond but calibrated it in a way that
would not cross red lines and
communicated that explicitly I mean he
said I'm seeing comments are you saying
that Trump is backing down actually the
message has been clear we don't want war
but ready for it I'm always surprised by
the same analysts describing Trump as a
calculating selfish cynic and as an
irrational crazed madman you have to
choose the rest is pretty standard peace
through strength more burden sharing
from allies in the Middle East jcpoa etc
Europeans should one welcome no
escalation to step up troop presence in
anti-terror in Middle East which will
also increase their diplomatic weight
and three try to put some meat in
trump's little diplomatic opening the
mention of common interests with Iran
against Isis getting questions on the
war under the Obama administration I'm
referring to it's Libya in 2011 this is
exactly right this is exactly right
people who are not friends with
President Trump are acknowledging that
Trump gets a win here Ian Bremmer who's
been no friend to President Trump over
the Eurasia group he's signaled today
that this is a pretty big win for Trump
it is a win for Trump more importantly
than a win for trumpets who win for the
United States because again the lie was
always at the rules of politics and
international affairs and force and
international affairs ceased to apply
when Donald Trump became president and
when Barack Obama became president Obama
so magically changed the world magically
changed the world that he could simply
sign a cheque to the Iranians and then
they would become wonderful neighbors to
everyone around them it was absolute
bullcrap from the very start and then
Trump comes in he kills soleimani he
ends the nuclear deal and then the logic
is well the world began spinning when
Barack Obama was president he had
magically checked so Trump magically
changed them back here's the reality
Iran has not changed its goals it has
not changed its orientations it has not
changed its tactics not one iota for 40
years they've been incredibly consistent
that tends to happen in dictatorships
the fact that the media want you to
believe that we were on the verge of
World War 3 here is demonstrative of the
fact that either the media don't know
what they're talking about or they're
malicious and I happen to think that it
is probably the latter okay meanwhile
impeachment is moving forward Nancy
Pelosi is now in a debate with Nancy
Pelosi about whether Nancy Pelosi ought
to release the impeachment charges to
the Senate she's being urged by members
of the Senate to do so because Mitch
McConnell says I'm gonna continue
forward with this impeachment trial
without naming witnesses which of course
is exactly what happened under the
Clinton administration during the
impeachment hearings about Bill Clinton
the Clinton Senate moved forward with
the procedure they said we will name the
witnesses later they ended up calling
like three witnesses and that was it
McConnell says I'm not gonna preset the
witness list we have to hear the
arguments from the house managers we
also are going to have to hear from the
prior witnesses presumably and then
we'll start talking about what exactly
comes next
and this of course has driven Pelosi to
the point of distraction she wants john
bolton to be named in the witness list
as though this is going to change things
radically I have serious doubts that
that is the case the new york times
running pieces about Mitch McConnell
being afraid of John Bolton maybe Mitch
McConnell is just not gonna cave to
Nancy Pelosi's pressure to do an
investigation where she refused to
remember the house could have called
John Bolton and waited on it they didn't
they didn't because Bolton probably was
not going to give them what they wanted
my favorite element of the whole
impeachment debacle is the theatrics
surrounding it yesterday
a bunch of impeachment protesters were
walking slowly around the the Senate
building that that wearing shirts that
suggested that Trump should be removed
bad that obviously he's gonna change
things radically a bunch of unemployed
morons in the middle of the day in
Washington DC walking slowly around the
Senate building first of all if I want
unemployment unemployable morons walking
around the Senate building we always
have senators I actually don't need
these people walking
be sent in building in order to push for
for impeachment I do love the one little
girl who's been dragged there by her
parents but at least she doesn't have to
go to school today now that they're
walking around the building slowly clear
under Article 39 of the Constitution I
believe the trump has automatically been
impeached Nancy Pelosi is going to have
to decide today whether or not she wants
to release those charges to the Senate
McConnell is going to move forward
either way her bluff has been called so
that basically ends that where it moves
from here it's probably a pretty quick
disposal I bolt in says something
earth-shattering which is very doubtful
at this point this whole thing is is
going to basically amount to nothing and
we'll all move on with our lives okay so
we don't actually have time for things I
like today so instead we'll do a very
very brief thing that I hate Elizabeth
Warren appeared on the view and
Elizabeth Warren's appearance on the
view was garbage as for her usual
arrangement first Meghan McCain had to
cuddle her into acknowledging that silly
money was a terrorist and then Elizabeth
Warren started just spewing nonsense
about Merrick garland so here is
Elizabeth Warren explaining that Merrick
that Mitch McConnell's handling of
Merrick garland was unconstitutional
which is amazing coming from a lady
proposing a wealth tax that is blatantly
unconstitutional when President Obama
nominated Merrick garland a Supreme
Court justice he had a year as a sitting
president yeah and when Mitch McConnell
just said sorry he's not getting a
hearing we're not even going to meet
with him the Constitution says the
president will nominate that's right and
the Senate will then offer its advise
and consent and you really want to in a
confirmation we never wrote it with the
assumption that oh you've got to say
within 30 days and then someone's got to
come out with unconstitutionally it's
unconstitutional to fully abide by the
Constitution and just say we're not
going to vote on this president's
nominee you don't have to vote on
anything I'm confused as Elizabeth
Warren think that Nancy Pelosi has a
duty to convey the impeachment charges
because she does not she can hold them
back and do whatever she wants if the
Constitution doesn't say you have to do
it you don't have to do it nothing says
that the Senate has to accede to a vote
on a Democratic nominee if the Senate
does not wish to alrighty we'll be back
here later today with two
additional hours of commentary also will
be back here tonight with daily wired
backstage I'm sure it will be very
heavily involved with Iran talk and
impeachment talk and we'll be back here
tomorrow so so much good stuff go over
to daily wire right now and subscribe if
you really want the behind the scenes
and all of our content otherwise we'll
see you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca dab poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Jess well alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]